un peu de calme avant que les clients
viennent en nombre il est 8h et le
marché de rambouillet sanou doucement en
ce matin de février
alors comme l'ail cet été c'est un petit
peu abîmés
de 3
pour compenser la ferme benoît fait
partie des plus anciens commerçants ces
maraîchers viennent tous les mercredis
et les samedis une histoire familiale
les parents de sophie ont un temps
suspendu leur présence en raison d'une
trop forte activité avant de revenir
proposer leurs produits les enfants ont
pris la relève depuis 35 ans on a eu
beaucoup de clients il y en avait un peu
moins malheureusement par exemple quand
le grand frais s'est installée on l'a
ressenti
voilà il ya toujours de la concurrence
faut se relever et l'alcôve il faut se
relever mais vous êtes toujours là on
est toujours là qui fasse froid comme
aujourd'hui payer moins de clients comme
aujourd'hui mais il a quand même la
clientèle les gens ont quand même envie
d'acheter s'achète pas de poireaux une
carotte c'est vraiment ont fait le plein
pour la famille
ils font de la publicité justement il ya
des fois ils prennent pour des amis pour
des voisins
donc voilà puis c'est des gens avec qui
on peut parler donc il ya une relation
amicale qui se créent en fait avec le
client des anciens mais aussi des petits
nouveaux sur la place de la mairie par
une odeur aller chez les gourmands et
les mal réveillé sont attirés par un
camion merci
ça porte un petit café oui le matin à
c'est très sympa le café le matin ça
c'est sûr et surtout il est excellent
ouais bon arlos koffi est l'un des
derniers exposants installés laura et
arnaud sont présents les samedis depuis
un peu moins d'un an leur particularité
un produit qu'on ne trouve pas souvent
sur les étals d'un marché du café ils
sont artisans torréfacteur
c'est notre plus gros marché on va dire
après il ya le fait qu'on soit conscient
local on est en bas du coup on est sûr
rambouillet donc donc ça nous tenait à
coeur d'être ici aussi fin c'était
logique on va dire d'être d'être ici et
je pense que les clients le ressentent
aussi le marché de rambouillet il est
très très bien une très bonne ambiance
assez convivial assez familial ici et on
a vraiment notre clientèle fidèle qui
vient vraiment tous les samedis donc
donc on aime beaucoup ce marché du coup
lieu d'achat et lieu de rencontre le
marché de rambouillet est aussi pour les
clients un moment d'échangé de
convivialité n'est du coup les aime tous
les samedis je suis au marché à part que
si je suis pas là c'est qu'il ya une
raison mais bon ça j'ai toujours marché
j'adore le marché j'ai toujours aimé ne
marche pas
toujours aimé le contact des gens
discussions le dialogue c'est de la
vente qu'on parle on rencontre du monde
les commerçants sont très sympathiques
et puis bon on trouve des bonnes choses
en plus j'ai habité à rouiller pendant
un an et du coup j'ai mes petites
habitudes même si ça fait très longtemps
et j'aime bien venir ici notamment sur
cet étal jusqu'à 100 commerçants se
rassemblent chaque samedi de 8 heures à
13 heures pour proposer de nombreux
produits aux clients boucherie
charcuterie fromagerie il n'y en a pour
tous les goûts la commune cherche à le
développer au sein de la future place de
la mairie c'est le plus grand marché du
sud du département deux autres marchés
plus intimiste sont organisées les
mercredis et dimanches